it's easier to think about it like
breeds of dogs so you hear a lot of dogs
that are called things like retrievers
like Labrador retrievers golden
retrievers they're all in like the same
family but you can kind of tell the
difference between them when you look at
them and what they do so scientists have
a way of telling them apart
so all of copán 19 is one specific type
rotavirus it's specifically like one
breed of dogs a Labrador and for us how
we tell this is we can look at the
genetic material inside of it but
essentially the virus is trying to
replicate hats on and more of and we can
get the sequence of it essentially like
reading the book that's inside of it and
we know all right a good sense you know
these certain things then it's this type
of virus so by getting that information
that's actually how we run tests to see
if people are sick with the flu or what
this virus is by looking at the
instruction than the virus and you read
it and say okay it's this type of virus
and the reason why to answer the part
about that here's something also that we
can do with that information because not
every species of animal needs that
genetic information the same way we can
look at features of it and they're sort
of like little bookmarks in the virus
that show where it came from and so we
look for those bookmarks to tell whether
like one has influenced where it's
coming because the virus uses the same
book smart bookmarks that its hosts us
so a virus for bats will have all of
that booklets I'm gonna buy risperdal
and it takes a while for those to go
away so sync this is new to us it
doesn't have human stuff yet so we can
still read all those and old that
bookmarks and say okay that's what
business what's written